how is he doing and how has the family
managed to get through this crisis uh
bronnie is doing uh extremely well um he
has uh began his um his rehab process to
um uh to get back on the floor um this
season um with his teammates in in USC
and um you know it was a successful um
surgery um that he had um but he's on up
and up um you know it's definitely a
worldwin and um a lot of tions um for
our family this this summer uh uh but
the best thing we have is each other and
uh and we stuck behind each other um and
gave bronnie strength um throughout the
whole process um and uh we happy to see
where he is today um and we look forward
to seeing um you know what his future um
still has in store for
him LeBron uh how you doing just to
follow up on that how has that just put
anything else into perspective for you
just as a parent and going through that
as you think about your career and your
family and and all of it heading into
year 21 uh nothing else matters besides
my family um and obviously I'm going
dedicate this um you know this season
because um to bronny because of um you
know the incident that happened this
summer and you know understanding that
it just puts everything in perspective
and no matter what's going on um you
know in your life at that point in time
that the only thing that matters is your
family um so um to see what he had to go
through um or what he's been through
through over the last few months um you
know it's been it's been a lot um I can
only imagine how it's been for him uh
cuz it's been a lot for me it's been a
lot for our family um but the man above
definitely has given us a lot of
strength and has given bronnie the
strength to to bounce back and uh if he
was to walk through the door right now
you wouldn't even you wouldn't even know
um that he had what he had because of
how how well he's moving um how vibrant
he is and um you know and um you know
it's just it's a beautiful thing to be
able to um to to have um you know him
where he is today and uh I give um the
biggest um compliment and the biggest
shout out and the biggest praise to the
USC uh training staff and coaching staff
um you know um you know when the
incident happened you know uh they were
Jimmy on the spot um they didn't waste
no time um and they were amazing in
their efforts to make sure that our um
that our son um was was very well taken
care of and um and also um you know
Cedar Cai as well um you know the M
Clinic in Rochester Minnesota um and
anybody else had anything to do with his
uh recovery and and U it's been it's
been an amazing thing